mais au bout du pont jacques gabriel le
promeneur est emmitouflé frigorifié mais
il profite pleinement à l'année dernière
on n'a pas une neige l'année dernière
mais là c'est vrai c'est très beau à
regarder des paysages ils sont vraiment
très beaux habits pittoresque
c'est dommage que les touristes vais
pouvoir savourer la butte touristes mais
nous on en profite quand même c'est bien
en ce moment la loire à vélo s'arrête là
le fleuve prend toute sa place et les
contemplatifs comme edith immortalise
ces instants gelés plutôt qu'un hacker
mais j'essaye de prendre aussi derrière
les beaux monuments de bois le rayon de
soleil étant là il fallait il fallait
venir en profiter
c'est très agréable la vue soit de bras
viennent sur le l'amphithéâtre de blois
est magnifique c'est après plaisir
regardez ça au pays des châteaux
le soleil fait éclater la blancheur de
la neige sur les ardoises et le tuffeau
nicolas a pris sa journée pour tirer
leur portrait hier j'ai serré avec une
amie à chambord et aujourd'hui il fait
beau donc j'ai fait quelques photos à
blois j'habite à blois et je me si
j'allais vous faire un petit tour pour
prendre le chef de ménard et chambord
sous la neige par contre avec le soleil
contrairement à hier matin
il
chambord une étape entre la source de la
loire et la mer pour ce couple venu du
sud de l'extérieur ça vaut le
déplacement
il fait très froid mais ça vaut le
déplacement surtout en camping car avec
-12 cette nuit c'était pas terrible mais
sinon c'est très joli
j'étais déjà venu quand j'étais petit
faire un âge ça doit avoir de la loire
avec ma mère mais là c'est magnifique
aussi on s'amuse c'est là vous avez
hambourg pour vous tout seul aujourd'hui
assez bien ça depuis la canardière
chambord offre son plus beau profil et
l'on trouve d'autres jouisseur de la vie
j'arrive du sud ouest avec mon ami
maxime et on vient juste prendre un
petit apéro dans le château de chambord
parce que j'ai jamais vu c'est une
réunion de chantier
donc c'est du télétravail mais devant le
château de chambord et après ça va se
passer près des barriques bien sûr il
fallait un peu de courage pour affronter
le froid
ensuite chaque paysage arrive comme un
cadeau une récompense de l'hiver
[Musique]